what was it like working on Star Wars
urines three of them was well I was
mainly in the Phantom Menace and we had
a very good time in Naples which is the
the Royal Palace of the Queen and one of
my one of my funny moments in Naples
actually I had a scene with one at one
of the decoy Queens this twelve-year-old
girl and we we both live in Twickenham
and I was talking to her about she was
she was that of Twickenham comprehensive
my daughter was that at Twickenham
comprehensive we were talking about
these two comprehensives and I thought I
can't believe I'm doing Star Wars and
I'm talking to this 12 year old girl
about tricking him comprehensives and it
was in fact Keira Knightley yes
Keira Knightley age 12 that got herself
into me yeah when I arrived there I saw
will Knightley her father who I've
worked with is very good actor and I
said Oh will they you in it and he said
no he said my daughter's in it and I
said but she's only about ten she's at
12 she's there well she's in it I'm not
and what kind of reaction did you get
your character in Star Wars well people
seem to like the character very much
because he's a very sort of benign
character I always say to people but he
spent most of his time giving good
advice that nobody took any notice of I
didn't know whether there was going to
be a little plastic model of me and I I
was in about batch six and a friend of
my daughter's working in Selfridges rang
my daughter and said Oh your dad's in
and and my daughter Miranda said Oh put
put won by said no I can't do that I'd
lose my job we've only got six next day
they'd sold out you see I couldn't find
any in London and I was doing a play in
New York and Tokyo I went to New York
they didn't have any in New York and I
went into the the toy shop in New York
fo Schwarz and they they had it the Star
Wars was playing on the television
and I was on it you see there was a CEO
Bibble and I said to the woman have you
got any co Bibble she said on Earth's
very rare it's very rare a CEO Bibble
and I said rather foolishly you see I I
am CEO Bibble and she looked at me
pissing Lee as if to say oh my god they
come in here they say they're Darth
Vader now I got this crummy Brit coming
in saying his Co member I don't know
what kind of it anyway there weren't any
in New York when we got to Tokyo at the
stage door there were suddenly fans with
all these when I said wait where did you
get that and they said kid either I went
down to the shop they had dozens and
dozens of Co Bibles that weren't selling
and it clearly all arrived in Tokyo I
couldn't get them New York but they send
them all to Tokyo now what do you think
about the return of star I was a bit
amazed by that of course but I suppose
Disney think that it will you know it
will attract people to come to it it
just depends how good the stories are
really how much they work on that and
how good how good the dialogue is to in
George very good on concept so sir on
the structure not so good on dialogue
probably shouldn't say that but how was
your thought that's one of the reasons
that George likes English actors British
actors because we're theater trained we
can hand all these very long sentences
you know and if you're Alec Guinness you
can make it sound like the wisdom of the
ages you know do you think you'd like to
see what JJ abrams does with these
franchise oh yeah I'd be interested and
you know he's a very interesting
director so you may might make something
of it yeah sure
you